so 600,000 to a million dollars we've
committed to for each employee and we've
set aside nothing zero
in late June 2012 Stockton California
filed chapter 9 bankruptcy motion
carries
six to one it wasn't the first
California City to do so and what's
happening in California is spreading to
the rest of the country but so far with
the population of just under 300,000 it
is the biggest municipality in US
history
to go bankrupt
an agricultural center located just
outside of San Francisco in California
Central Valley Stockton was a booming
suburb in the 1990s providing an
affordable living alternative to the
pricey real estate of the Bay Area
living large off the new property taxes
created by the housing bubble the city
government spent lavishly on big public
works projects like a Waterfront Park an
arena and a brand new city hall which
sits nearly empty as the city government
could never actually afford to move in
promotional flyers still remain
plastered two empty buildings downtown
reminders of a more hopeful time but
even all this spending pales in
comparison to the magnitude of
Stockton's public employee pension and
benefit obligations the city now faces
more than eight hundred million dollars
in unfunded liabilities for pensions and
other employee benefits we're saddled
with this debt we don't have the
revenues anymore to to service with
revenue dwindling in the wake of the
housing crash Stockton issued a one
hundred twenty five million dollar bond
in 2007 to help fill the budget gap but
the back end loaded bond saddled the
city with an annual payment of 16 eight
million dollars as of this year with
ballooning payments rising to twenty-two
point three million next year and nearly
doubling to thirty point two million by
2020 I was really shocked by how deep it
went by how ingrained it was it had
really created a culture what was best
for for the city and what was best for
its employees not necessarily what was
best for the public
Miller describes a political culture in
which generous and out's to public
employee unions were masked through
tricky accounting of a savvy city
manager who enabled local government
officials to give in to nearly every
union demand the quality of that
information that the county
received in the 1990s from ven city
manager Dwayne Mills was not complete it
was not always accurate and in some
cases I think it was almost misleading
Dwayne Mills was Stockton City Manager
in the 90s and signed off on many of
these benefit packages in retrospect we
should have been more restrictive in
that plan that we were but we didn't
know what was going to happen Mills now
runs Stockton's Association of Retired
employees which is fighting to preserve
many of those very same benefits he now
admits we're a mistake for the city
these are vested rights if you have a
need to reduce them you need to come
talk to us
Mills doesn't believe that he or the
City Council members he advised are to
blame for Stockton's dire situation and
says that the economic downturn would
have put Stockton here with or without
the public spending binge I've seen
cities that have the same pension system
are paying pretty much the same pension
rates that Stockton is doing and are not
about ready to fall off the cliff so
when you ask who's going to tip over
it's not who is providing the pension
benefits it's who's providing the
pension benefits in an economic
environment that they can't support it
but Reason Foundation senior policy
analyst Adam summers says that Stockton
story is becoming an increasingly common
one as public officials have no
incentive to rein in spending before
hitting the brink you're going to
continue to see more and more cities
kind of going the way of Stockton and
San Bernardino and Vallejo there's a
real kind of moral hazard whereby they
have incentives to offer goodies to
people knowing that they won't have to
bear the cost of those decisions in
Stockton we had city manager who
publicly has stated he didn't like
having to negotiate every year with his
public employee unions and so he granted
generous long-term contracts because he
didn't he didn't want to do it
malarkey you know she was not in the
closed sessions when
when we were very very clear with the
City Council in detail what was being
negotiated what the cost of those things
were I'm the last guy who's going to
tell you what it is you want to hear
putting the history for the bad deal
aside today's reality is that the
unfunded retiree benefits on top of the
extensive borrowing to pay for fancy new
buildings has gutted the city's general
fund a bulk of which is now devoted to
paying back loans though it's supposed
to pay for the most basic government
services like police and fire when
cities make promises they can't keep
whether its pensions or some sort of
boondoggle project that gets them into a
lot of debt those eat up resources that
could be spent for public safety or
education one result is that Stockton's
police force shrank by 26% in four years
and last year Stockton had a record 58
murders half way into 2012 they've
already had 34 doctors a very dangerous
place to live the number of business
robberies are going up the number of car
auto burglaries with auto thefts
shootings people are more likely to be a
victim of a crime than they've ever been
before in their life
Catherine Nance is a police sergeant and
member of the Stockton Police Officers
Association which has several lawsuits
against the city they kept spending to
build and build and build on things they
couldn't afford we're now below market
value and unable to retain and recruit
people but in yet another example of the
city's loose accounting three of the
last four police chiefs served fewer
than three years in Stockton and used
the inflated salaries in those final
years of their service to retire with
massive pensions some of which exceed
$200,000 a year while the last remnants
of a fading movement occupy one of the
city's nearly empty public parks Kathy
Miller says it's not corporate pay but
public sector pay that's out of sync
with reality in Stockton the gap widened
between what they were earning and what
the average taxpayer was earning I mean
this is in a county where the average
working person earns less than $50,000 a
year
while California's state-run pension
system CalPERS has left cities
particularly vulnerable to budget
meltdowns Summers warns that the problem
isn't confined to the Golden State
cities around the country have made a
lot of the same poor decisions as they
have here in California and so rising
pension costs are going to continue to
put a stress on local budgets I think
more cities are going to have to follow
the example of San Diego and San Jose
they've recently switched over to a 401
K style defined contribution pension
system for all the city's employees
except for police officers and you know
really the the private sector has been
going this way for thirty years now this
is not a partisan issue at all this is a
good government issue and I think when
we get out of touch with that and we
begin acting like it's our money it's
not the people's money that's where you
get into real serious problems
Stockton officials hope bankruptcy will
allow the city to opt out of some of its
more stifling contracts and to avoid
repaying all of its creditors in full
while maintaining some money in the
general fund to keep its most basic city
services the city has already been
downgraded by credit ratings agencies
which will severely restrict its
borrowing ability retirees probably
won't be seeing the benefits that were
promised by city officials and taxpayers
aren't likely to see improved city
services anytime soon but with cities
across the country locked into expensive
long-term public employee contracts
Stockman's title as the largest US city
to ever go bankrupt might be short-lived
you